على الهواء مباشره هذه الصوره الحصريه
للعربيه نلاحظ تصاعد لاعمده الدخان في
المنطقه المحيطه بالقياده العامه هذه
الصور الان تحدث في محيط القياده العامه
هنالك نستمع كذلك معها الى اصوات تبادل
لاطلاق الرصاص وكذلك ايضا اصوات المدفعيه
الخفيفه والمتوسطه والثقيله نستمع الى صوت
الطبيعي ونعود اليك الاستاذ الطاهر سادتي
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا يعني هكذا تصل الصوره الان
هذا صباح اليوم الخامس تجدد للاشتباكات
اشتباكات عنيفه جدا الان تحدث في محيط
القياده العامه تصاعد لاعمده الدخان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات